we suppress it and mr. director-general
all delegates and dear friends first let
me welcome to the city of Milan I'm
pleased and honored to hear that you are
more than 3,000 attending this
conference and I'm sure that this is due
to the very importance of the conference
but I hope that it's also due to the
city of Milan so thank you very much let
me very briefly in my speech give you
some example of what we are doing the
city and why we believe this conference
is so important and why we believe that
the development of fiber optics is so
important the fiber to the home council
promotes in the world an idea which is
we believe fundamental for the
development the connection to the
network's along which knowledge travels
optical fiber is one of the devices to
which the same can be attained all the
economic growth indicators including
these presented during the conference
clearly show that the air is
characterized by a larger economic
growth the most innovative cities and
the most dynamic systems are those that
can benefit from the highest
availability of fast connection the
availability of the connection and the
diffusion of the optical fiber is high
in the most dynamic economic in the
world and I'm thinking about South Korea
or the diffusion of the fiber optic
network inside the building exceed fifty
percent but also about Japan about Uncle
Taiwan and as far as Europe is concerned
the two engines performance is very
interesting but also Milan it's an
interesting example belen is one of the
most dynamic cities in this field it is
a virtual example of a highly innovative
economic capital which in few years has
been able to create and I have to
mention years in advance if compared to
other cities the largest fiber-optic
network
in Europe with the two hundred and
seventy-five thousand kilometers of
optical fiber fiber we added many others
European cities today our network
connect 2.5 million homes and 348,000
subscriber it is used to study carry on
research have fun create and provide
services culture and business this is
one of the reason why Melanie's honor to
host the 2011 edition of the feet ft th
comes in Europe Milan can be a perfect
lab for the creation of strategy for the
diffusion of connectivity as an
instrument of development development
travels on the net through the exchange
of data the creation of networked
collaboration structure our country has
entered into the ftth ranking of the
countries with the better diffusion of
optical fiber service among the families
thanks to the success of Milan that has
been able to build in this field Milan
which is a dynamic and innovative
economy which account for ten percent of
the Italian GDP has the same number of
patents are she filed every year as
Boston has and has a number of high-tech
company which is approximately 15,000
high-tech company out of around 300,000
companies located in the cities of Milan
Milan is aware of the responsibility of
having these strong Network and being
a tool of development and when I speak
about Milan I speak about the research
centers the universities but also the
cultural excellences that have always
been a focus on the importance of
international collaboration and i just
want to mention last gala i want to
mention fashion and design and
researchers symbols of the the opening
of the city of Milan and today malena
has another big chance but also a
challenge and a responsibility villain
will host the universal Expo 2015 after
the very successful expo of fashion guy
the millennia expo will not be an
exhibition of the successor tane by
technology nor it will leave monumental
or celebrity of buildings it will be an
expo of knowledge of exchange of
information and the best practice
concerning the themes of the same
sustainability development sustainable
development involving the excellence of
the world so we really hope that this
export will truly be a universal Expo
that can be connected also on our fiber
optic way that is why the Milan Expo is
the expo of the net the expedient more
than any other will be connected to the
world through the internet today in
Milan seventy percent of the street
sixty percent of the buildings and
eighty percent of estates are wired with
optical fiber moreover fifteen percent
of which Italian enterprises working in
this sector twenty percent of research
thirty-seven percent of National patents
and 54 of the total turnover a base de
in Milan
the Polytechnical Milan is the leader in
the net industry at a national level all
of these will be part of Milan Expo 2015
and export will make it even better to
the advantage of Milan but not only in
advantage of milan in advantage of all
the cities of the world which will like
to be connected and not only the cities
but also the private sector which is
vital and fundamental i would just
conclude by mentioning two examples of
the city of Milan on the sector of fiber
optics first all life long learning the
net delivers knowledge but it also
creates employment updating possibility
of getting back to labor market millen
we have just issues an invitation to
tender for enterprises offering
continuing education and Retraining to
the employees for an amount of 4 million
euros all the educational activities of
the plan are based on the net both for
on-site learning and distance learning
elearning is widespread in Milan thanks
to the high connectivity the city can
today offer I would also like to mention
health in Mullane we have the most
advanced centres of research and
treatment for specific pathologies and
therapies in Europe millennion Lombardi
health services is among the most
computer aiza of the continent thanks to
the exchange of information between the
different structures again the net is
synonymous of improved research and L
the Milan Expo together with the
Ministry of Health sign an agreement
protocol to promote new technologies for
diagnosis and therapy by means of
dedicated networks and these networks
need high connectivity these are just a
few example of the benefit that high
connection system guarantee these are
situation we are experiencing Milan but
we are also here to learn about what you
are doing in other country we are here
to learn on what you are doing in other
cities we are here to learn water
companies and private enterprises can do
we believe that their opportunity of
sustainable development is very much
based on new technology and fiber optic
is certainly a very important tool we
believe in exchange of experience we
believe in a work which is not
separating the public to the private
sector by the work which take together
the best of one and the best of the
other so we believe that working
together we can build a better word and
fiber optic is certainly a way to build
a better world thank you and all the
best for the conference and I hope you
will have some time to enjoy the city
thank you very much